fabelwesen und fantastische figuren
cosplayer erwecken charaktere aus manga
comics anime trickfilmen und fantasy
geschichten zum leben
lisa logan um ist eine von ihnen als
wächterin albedo aus dem japanischen
anime overlord wandelt die 26-jährige
durch die hallen der leipziger buchmesse
den schauplatz der menschen allein in
deutschland stützen regelmäßig geschätzt
15.000 cosplayer in fremde rollen
weltweit begeistern mangas animes und
comics millionen
vor allem in japan den usa und europa
als die szene aktiv lisa london um
faszinieren manga seit ihrer kindheit
vor acht jahren beginnt sie mit dem
cosplay die kostüme entwirft sie dabei
selbst eine voraussetzung um in der
szene ernst genommen zu werden
die vorlage aus dem anime übersetzt sie
in eine skizze und fertigt daraus das
schnittmuster all das hat sie sich
selbst beigebracht
an die 50 cosplay outfits sind so schon
entstanden
manche sind innerhalb eines tages fertig
an anderen wie dem aktuellen kostüm
arbeitet sie mehrere monate
das ist halt glaube ich nie herausholen
beim cosplay dass man selber was
kreieren entwerfen muss was halt so noch
nicht da ist
das ist glaube ich für viele cosplayer
so einen anreiz man sagt das sieht so
toll aus und ich würde es eigentlich
selber machen
jetzt habe ich da was geschaffen und hab
mir auf den kopf gemacht der steckt halt
auch viel arbeit und zeit brenner viel
geld wo man sagt da braucht man viel
fantasie und kreativität cosplayer ist
ein teures hobby
die meisten kostüme verschlingen oft
mehrere hundert euro allein an
materialkosten vor allem extras wie
dieses flügelpaar sind aufwendig wieder
herstellen
lisa norden um heißt eigentlich lisa
augstein und arbeitet als medizinisch
technische angestellte für ihr hobby
experimentiert sie immer wieder mit
neuen materialien zum beispiel mit
thermoplastischen stoff erhitzt lässt
sich der in jede gewünschte form bringen
diese rüstung mit all ihren einzuteilen
ist ihr bislang wichtigstes projekt das
man sich halt natürlich dass man das
geschafft hat
erst durch ein kleines aber
wirkungsvolles detail wird das cosplay
auf wird richtig vollständig farbige
kontaktlinsen
praktisch ist es nicht weit also man
muss ein abstriche machen man muss sich
halt mein tag mit einer haarsträhne im
gesicht rumlaufen
man macht sind halt nur für die
convention oder welt für fotos aber wer
sagt denn dass kosten und bequem ist
zurück auf der leipziger buchmesse
lisa orban um unterwegs als wächterin
albedo und jedem der vier messetage
kommt sie in einem anderen kostüm
umso wichtiger sind die fotos von jedem
einzelnen jennifer maske hat sich auf
cosplay fotografie spezialisiert ist das
foto im endeffekt das fertig bearbeitete
foto sowieso gelandet riesengroß für die
kosten
ziemlich zeigen für diese warnung ist
die manga comic con auf der leipziger
buchmesse der höhepunkt des jahres
vor allem weil sie ihr anerkennung von
den fans bekommt sowieso
cosplayer lassen die fantasiewelten der
mangas und animes mit viel fantasie
realität werden zumindest für einen tag